מחשוב אחראי מובן
כפיתוח של quantum computing
תוך מודעות לכוחו
והשפעותיו הפוטנציאליות כשאנחנו אומרים אחראי
אנחנו צריכים לפתח ולהשתמש בטכנולוגיה
על בסיס עקרונות מוגדרים מראש שיעזרו לנו למנוע
ולהפחית נזקים פוטנציאליים
תוך קידום פתרונות שהם באופן יזום
כוללים ואחראיים ב-IBM
הנחה אותנו תחושת אחריות
כלפי החברה במשך עשורים היום אנחנו מכנים את עצמנו זרז
שמשפר את העולם זה אומר שיש לנו
את האחריות לשקול את ההשלכות של
הטכנולוגיות שאנחנו בונים ועוזרים להפעיל
כשאנחנו מפתחים את הטכנולוגיה החדשה הזאת
ההחלטות שנקבל היום ישפיעו על העתיד
וההחלטות האלה
יכולות להיות בעלות השפעה עצומה על החברה
למשל יכול להיות שתצטרך להחליט אם לקדם יישום
שמועיל רק לכמה בעלי עניין או
אחד שיכול לפתור בעיה חברתית
אנחנו מקווים שאתה כלקוח תוכל לחשוב
על פיתוח אחראי של quantum computing
חשיבה אחראית יכולה לעזור לעסק שלך לבסס אמון
עם משקיעים וצרכנים
תוך בניית מוניטין של יושרה
והערכה בקרב העובדים שלך
והלקוחות שלך ומצד שני
זה יכול לעזור להגן עליך מפני פרסום שלילי וקנסות
ועונשים בסרטון הזה
נציג שיקולי אחריות חשובים
לדיון עם הצוות
בזמן שאתם חוקרים quantum computing
ויישומיו כשמדובר ב-quantum computing
חשיבה ופעולה אחראית
אומרת לפעול לפי קבוצת עקרונות
וערכים שמנחים את הפיתוח שלך
ופריסת הטכנולוגיה
למשל זה אומר להיות שקוף
לגבי המגבלות והיכולות
של quantum computing היום יש לנו שפה
בחוזים שלנו שמחייבת לקוחות IBM Quantum
להשתמש במערכות שלנו באופן אחראי
ושהם לא ישתמשו במערכות שלנו
למטרות זדוניות או בלתי חוקיות
אנחנו קוראים לאלה סעיפי שימוש אחראי
ושימוש מקובל שלנו
השפה הזאת כבר משפיעה על אופן החשיבה של הלקוחות שלנו
על פיתוח quantum
עבור מקרי השימוש שלהם אנחנו יכולים
גם לעזור לכוון את הכיוון של quantum computing
על ידי החלטה אילו יישומים אנחנו מקדמים
לפיתוח ולהאצה
כדי להגן מפני שימושים לא אחראיים פוטנציאליים
בטכנולוגיה שלנו פיתחנו גם טכנולוגיית IBM Quantum
בטוחה כשאתה חושב על איך
ולמה להשתמש ב-quantum computing
תדאג לדבר בצורה ריאליסטית על הציפיות שלך
מ-quantum computing ועל לוחות הזמנים
שבהם אתה מקווה לשלב quantum
אל תציג quantum computing
כמסתורי אלא נסה להסביר אותו באופן ריאליסטי
וכחומרת מחשוב
שפועלת לפי חוקי הפיזיקה הקוונטית
תוודא שמקרה השימוש שלך ב-quantum computing
הוא כולל באופן יזום
ולוקח בחשבון את כל בעלי העניין הפוטנציאליים
כדי לקבוע את מידת
ההשפעות החברתיות השליליות
תוודא שיש לך עקרונות ברורים מוגדרים
וערכים לחקירת מקרה השימוש שלך
ולפיתוח תודה
על הצפייה אנחנו מקווים ש
כשאתה מביא quantum computing שימושי לעולם
תחשוב גם על איך אתה יכול לעשות את זה באחריות.
ה ה